I host the television program on
Discovery Channel called Expedition
unknown and we were thinking about the
idea of making a special on Titanic and
so we went up to Ocean Gates
headquarters in Everett Washington in
2021 this was just before they were
going to take their first group of
passengers down to Titanic and we went
out with Stockton the CEO who is
piloting uh Titan on this current
Mission as well and we joined Stockton
for a Shakedown dive on the sub taking
it out putting it through its Paces
there in Puget Sound and and seeing how
Titan performed and thinking about
whether it would be a good fit for us to
to film for a show it's a really
striking submarine as you'll see in the
in the stock footage of it here it's a
very novel uh design it doesn't look
like any other submersible that has gone
down to Titanic before and a lot of that
has to do with how it's made it's made
of carbon fiber Hull as opposed to
having a steel or a titanium Hull and
because it's carbon fiber it could be
made much larger so it's actually quite
a large submarine can hold five people
as opposed to most of the subs that go
down to Titanic and only hold two or
three so it's actually quite spacious
inside as these kind of Subs go uh and
as I said it has a very unique design so
it's certainly when you when you see it
it's a fairly striking craft
uh yeah Josh you use words like novel
and unique when it comes to its design
and you know Ocean Gate itself when you
look at its website talks about being at
the Forefront of innovation in fact it's
so Innovative it's ahead of Regulation
you know regulation can't keep up with
its innovation
but was it safe did you get the feeling
that it was safe did you talk to those
that operated it about the safety
measures involved and the kind of risks
involved tell us a bit about that
yeah you look this is one of the really
challenging things about a vehicle like
this is that there is almost nothing to
Benchmark it against there is no other
vehicle like Titan anywhere in the world
it is a one-off and so evaluating risk
for a craft like this is really
difficult we know that carbon fiber is
extremely strong it's what's used to
build the Boeing Dreamliner or the
Airbus a350 it is a miracle product in a
lot of ways it can be 10 times stronger
than than steel but there are real
questions about carbon fiber in terms of
uh it's fatigue how does it perform at
these kind of pressures and if this kind
of a cold temperature after multiple
Cycles it's something that's hard to
evaluate and so risk is a very difficult
thing to evaluate when it comes to Titan
for us on the Dives that we did I would
say that some of the systems on board
perform very well some of them didn't
perform well at all we had issues with
thrusters we had issues with computer
control aboard but of course this was a
a test designed to kind of get tightened
up and running for the Voyages it was
going to make a few months later those
kind of things aren't uncommon on a test
dive having said that ultimately I
decided to back off of our project
because I just couldn't get comfortable
ultimately with the design of Titan
because there was so little data
available about managing that risk and
really what it looked like if this sub
went up and down as many times as it was
going to
remind me how long ago that was because
you know Ocean Gate and the number of
Dives it's made since you were there on
that sort of Maiden Shakedown dive as
you call it it seems that you know
safety wasn't a concern for those going
on those trips and there are waivers
involved everybody's well away from the
risk that the mention of of death
apparently on the first page of the way
there is mentioned three times you know
yeah this was in 2021 yeah this was in
2021 when we uh went and did this with
Ocean Gate that was at the beginning of
its real Maiden season of bringing
passengers out there for the first time
and look it is described in those
waivers as an experimental craft and I
think that it is truly experimental in a
very real sense of the word this is not
like boarding a commercial flight on a
new airplane this is like being a test
pilot on a plane that has never flown
before and so there's a there's a
totally different category of risk with
a vehicle like this I do think the
passengers Are Made made aware of a lot
of those risks but again there are just
a huge number of unknowns with a
submersible like this there are elements
of Titan where there are real
redundancies there there are a lot of
ways to drop weights for instance on
Titan and bring it back to the surface
there's four different systems on board
to drop weights there's a
computer-controlled system that can vent
water in or out of ballast Chambers to
help it rise up in the ocean there is a
manual valve in Titan to to take air and
add it to bladders on the outside of the
sub to bring it up and there's a
hydraulic controlled system that can
drop weights off the bottom and in fact
the entire skid assembly on the bottom
of Titan can be dropped using a
hydraulic lever which takes a huge
amount of weight off the sub to bring it
to the surface those sort of things were
were baked into the design of Titan to
make it more safe but there are other
elements of its design that are more
challenging you know it cannot be opened
from the inside there is no top side
hatch on Titan because of the way the
carbon fiber Hull is built uh and and so
you have these trade-offs you have an
Innovative novel design but it comes
with a lot of with a lot of mysteries
and you know in terms of how it's going
to perform over time yeah it is a real
mystery at the moment while those
session and rescue teams try to find it
and just that's really interesting
information in terms of
the security measures on board the sub
that if something goes wrong like you
said you've just talked us through a
whole raft of things that the crew on
board can do in light of that what do
you think has happened what could have
gone wrong in terms of you know it's not
floated to the surface what are the kind
of things that could have got a ride
down there
you know I it's tough to speculate about
this I think in some ways there are only
a handful of things
um categories of things that that could
go wrong
um one of the real uh you know
challenges here is communication it's
very hard to communicate with untethered
Subs like this from the surface anyway
but the fact that Titan lost
communication on its way down to Titanic
um and that they have not received
communication since then would indicate
that something uh went wrong with its
systems now it was well off the bottom
when that communication was lost and so
using those multiple redundancies of
weight drop systems Titan should have
returned to the surface right and so the
fact that that hasn't happened opens up
this whole other question of what are
these other possibilities you know look
certainly one of those possibilities is
a whole failure that kind of speaks to
the carbon fiber design of of um of
Titan and also a concern in all
submersibles
um electrical fires uh computer failure
things like that I have to say I I think
we're still in the in the time period
here here though though this time period
is closing where I think we should
remain hopeful we've got five people
aboard this sub we have a young man
aboard this sub and all of these new
assets are now rushing out to the North
Atlantic to Aid in this search and so I
think that
um you know we we should remain hopeful
here for a positive outcome for this uh
which is what everybody here wants
obviously
um and uh we're going to know more about
that I think in the next day or so here
um Josh what are the the big questions
being asked by everyone that follows
this story is why why do this
given this incident of course we don't
know the outcome of it yet it's not
looking good but like you said we cling
on to Hope
um do you think this is the end of this
kind of expedition involving this kind
of submersible who's going to want to
get into one of these ever again and
again it comes back to that question why
do you want to do this you're someone
that does this talk us through that
right
well look you know I this is a big
question and it's something that
especially on social media people seem
to be talking about a lot I think
there's actually been a lot of
um quite you know Palace comments on
social media I've been reading from
people who just say why why should
anybody ever attempt something like this
look I think first of all it's important
to remember that Titanic has
um has fascinated the world since the
night that she sank you know there is an
incredible Allure to this shipwreck and
indeed to all shipwrecks I think because
they are time capsules and they are
transportative they they bring us to a
moment in our own past in the case of
Titanic to a to a gilded uh age in a lot
of ways and so they hold a real
Fascination for people
um both uh you know just um as a matter
of interest but also to historians and
to scientists uh and and so I think that
you know the people aboard Titan uh I
think were there because they had a real
passion and a real interest for Thai
Titanic and uh as as someone who manages
risk for a living and who does a lot of
risky things look it takes a lot of
courage and a lot of determination to go
on a voyage like this in a submarine
down to these kind of depths and so I
think there should be a lot of
admiration for the people aboard Titan
because I think this is something that
speaks to their passion you know there
are people who climb Everest there are
people who parachute and many of us
would say why do those things and those
people would say because it's something
that speaks to them on a personal level
on a deep level uh and and so I think
this is the case with with Titanic it is
a difficult place to reach it is a it is
an event that holds a huge place in our
in our history and I think that these
people had admirable goals going down
there
um and and I commend them for for having
the passion and determination to take a
take a trip like this down to Titanic